bienvenidos a la entrevista de frente 24
soy luis muñoz y en esta emisión nos
acompaña felipe stefan director para
américa de illumina una organización que
se define filantrópica y cuyo objetivo
es empoderar a personas e instituciones
para que trabajen juntas en aras de
construir sociedades más justas en ese
esfuerzo acaban de publicar un informe
sobre juventudes y democracia en américa
latina' examinando la relación entre
jóvenes y democracia en argentina brasil
colombia y méxico felipe muchas gracias
por estar en france 24
muchísimas gracias triste después de
leer el estudio no sé si te queda la
misma conclusión que a mí los jóvenes en
latinoamérica apoyan la democracia a
pesar de todo
los jóvenes en américa latina están
teniendo una imagen menos favorable cada
día de la democracia pero no es porque
no apoyen la democracia si apoyan la
democracia pero su frustración es con
los partidos políticos con las
instituciones políticas y con los
líderes políticos el problema que tiene
no es necesariamente con la idea de la
democracia o con la democracia como un
sistema político el problema que tienen
es con cómo la democracia está operando
hoy en día una joven brasileña dice en
el informe que su forma de activismo es
compartiendo dando me gusta mientras que
en colombia los jóvenes consideran que
incluso el paro nacional las protestas
que vivieron en 2021 mejoraron la
democracia el activismo digital es más
cómodo para los gobiernos
el activismo digital es una de las
maneras a través de las cuales los
jóvenes están participando en la
democracia hoy en día lo que vemos en
las democracias de américa latina es que
hay una crisis de representatividad
quienes están en el poder y quienes
gobiernan no representan ni la
diversidad de la población a quien
gobiernan ni los intereses
particularmente de jóvenes minorías
raciales y étnicas o grupos lg vete y en
el hacer política siendo así los jóvenes
siempre van a querer buscar cómo
participar en la política y eso lo hacen
en persona como lo vimos en las
protestas recientes en colombia y en
bogotá donde muchos de los jóvenes en el
estudio expresan haberse sentido más
partícipes en la democracia por haber
podido protestar y hacer escuchar sus
voces y sus recomendaciones o
digitalmente como lo estamos viendo cada
día más en países en la región lo que sí
es cierto es que no es suficiente que
los jóvenes hagan clic o compartan
causas
social es un activismo que
verdaderamente vaya a transformar la
democracia latinoamericana
requiere una participación activa de los
jóvenes tanto al momento de votar como
en el momento en el que se están tomando
las decisiones que impactan su día y el
futuro de sus comunidades hablabas de la
desconfianza de los jóvenes en las
instituciones y de hecho en el informe
un mexicano dice textualmente no confío
en mi sombra mucho menos en los
políticos a lo largo del estudio se ve a
la cita las instituciones como un otro
como algo extraño están desconectadas
estas de la sociedad para que produzcan
esa sensación
las instituciones hoy en día muchas
veces no producen los resultados que los
ciudadanos y las ciudadanas esperan y se
merecen es más en muchos casos ni
siquiera crean procesos para escuchar a
la ciudadanía y para entender
verdaderamente que quieren y que buscan
y cómo los pueden servir de una mejor
manera hay una brecha entre los
ciudadanos y las instituciones y eso
también tiene que ver con los resultados
que producen las instituciones en
ciertos casos la democracia en nuestros
países ha llevado a incrementos en la
desigualdad diferentes personas
dependiendo las oportunidades y los
privilegios que tienen tienen una
experiencia diferente de la democracia
en que en muchos casos quienes más
tienen y quienes más privilegios y
oportunidades tienen se sienten muy bien
con la manera en la que las
instituciones están respondiendo a sus
necesidades mientras que quienes menos
tienen no tienen confianza con las
instituciones porque no tienen razón por
la cual tener confianza simplemente
porque no han visto los resultados de
las instituciones
en lo que sí coinciden y es
especialmente interesante de ver es como
tanto en argentina como en brasil como
en colombia o en mexico que son los
sujetos de estudios las mujeres
reivindican el feminismo es esta una
ruptura grande con generaciones
anteriores
hay una sensación en américa latina' que
está basada en los hechos de
representatividad en los congresos en
los senados y cambias de representantes
en la presidencia y los ministerios
también en los juzgados de que las
mujeres están sub representadas
la política y creo que eso viene de una
cultura en américa latina' que por mucho
tiempo ha definido a la política a
través de unos lentes que tienen que ver
con temas de patriarcado y machismo en
los cuales las mujeres han tenido menos
oportunidad de ser consideradas como
líderes en sus países y en los casos en
los que sí han tenido estas
oportunidades como por decir es el caso
de brasil ha habido una constante de
legitimización de su liderazgo político
y creo que en brasil el estudio por
decir muestra en mujeres conservadoras y
mujeres liberales están de acuerdo en
ciertos temas del feminismo en lo que
concierne a la representación política
de mujeres puede que estén en desacuerdo
sobre otros los temas por decir el tema
del aborto es uno de los temas donde las
mujeres dependiendo de cómo piensan
políticamente pueden tener una posición
u otra pero dónde están de acuerdo es
que no hay suficientes mujeres en
política también en el informe se lee
como en colombia algunos jóvenes llegan
a decir que tienen miedo a ser
asesinados por la policía cuando
participan en marchas es una institución
que también sufre un gran rechazo en
otros países de la región ha
evolucionado la institución policial
desde esas etapas más oscuras del
continente en américa latina' y esas
dictaduras militares o en por ejemplo en
colombia en la lucha contra las
guerrillas
américa latina está viendo una tendencia
muy marcada y muy preocupante hacia la
militarización de la policía y hacia el
uso inadecuado de la fuerza en contra de
personas que están expresando como lo es
su derecho cívico sus posiciones en el
contexto de protestas y marchas y
también de líderes sociales y activistas
es increíblemente problemático que en un
país como méxico donde desde el 2000 se
asesina a un periodista por mes solo en
lo que va de este año 2022 ya se hacen
hacen ha asesinado más de 4 periodistas
o personas asociadas con medios colombia
hoy en día es el país del mundo con
mayor asesinatos de líderes sociales y
ambientales solo hace un par de semanas
a una activista adolescente ambiental lo
asesinaron por su activismo y lo que es
muy cierto es que mientras la policía o
los militares dependiendo lo que sea en
cada país estén utilizando la fuerza
para no permitirle a la ciudadanía que
se exprese eso a generar mayor
desconfianza y mayores problemas entre
las autoridades y las instituciones y
los ciudadanos y las ciudadanas y lo que
tenemos es que permitir que haya un
espacio para la protesta social para la
movilización y un diálogo entre
ciudadanía e instituciones donde puedan
crear juntos las soluciones que queremos
ver en la sociedad mientras los policías
sigan matando a los activistas nunca
vamos a poder crear una democracia
verdaderamente efectiva como la que nos
merecemos dos latinoamericanos una
pregunta relacionada es que américa
latina es la región más desigual del
mundo incluso en estas protestas de los
últimos años nosotros tuvimos la
experiencia en cali cuando estuvimos el
pasado año en las protestas de colombia
como muchos jóvenes decían que estaban
dispuestos incluso a morir por la
desesperación que tenían una sociedad
una sociedad más justa mejoraría la
relación de los jóvenes con los estados
una democracia que funcione de manera
correcta debería ser una democracia que
esté produciendo sociedades más justas
donde más personas tengan acceso a
oportunidades hoy en día de donde vengas
y de dónde naciste y el color de tu piel
tu sexualidad tu raza tu religión son
factores determinantes en las
oportunidades que tienes sin justicia no
hay democracia y una democracia que siga
creando desigualdades es en una
democracia que nunca va a generar
confianza entre los ciudadanos y ahí es
donde nos encontraríamos en un problema
muy significativo si los ciudadanos
deciden que la democracia por la forma
en la que la experiencia en estos días
no produce los resultados y nunca
producirá los resultados que ellos
quieren ver van a dejar de luchar por
construir y reconstruir esa democracia y
volveríamos a ver una oportunidad para
que líderes autoritarios u otro tipo de
regímenes incluyendo regímenes militares
pudieran surgir porque el actor
extracción con la democracia llegaría a
un nivel tan alto
entonces para prevenir eso hay que re
imaginar una democracia una democracia
que sea más justa en la que entendamos
que la diversidad y la equidad son
factores centrales para que los países
puedan construir una futura prosperidad
y para acabar felipe una última pregunta
tradicionalmente la caricatura ha sido
perseguida e incluso también censurada
pero su posibilidad de ejercicio era
síntoma de una buena salud democrática
actualmente los jóvenes lo que usan son
los memes que podríamos trasladar esa
comparación y muchos jóvenes se informan
a través de esta forma de estos memes su
libre uso del de los memes indica aún
una buena salud de la libertad de
expresión en la región
los memes definitivamente indican que
hay una calidad democrática y de la
libertad de expresión los discursos que
hemos tenido sobre libertad de expresión
y los debates que hemos tenido sobre
derechos de expresión derechos de
privacidad ahora son muy importantes en
el ámbito digital y lo que es más
crucial es que podamos proteger la
libertad de expresión el derecho a que
las personas para expresarse ya sea con
caricaturas con memes con discursos
políticos a través de sus redes sociales
y si lo quieren hacer mientras que
prevengamos sobre la distribución de
información falsa porque lo que está
pasando en este momento con los jóvenes
es que están consumiendo la mayoría de
la información política a través de los
redes sociales y cuando consumen
información a través de redes sociales y
de influencers esos influencers tienen
incentivos para producir y publicar
información que sea controversial que
sea polarizante y eso hace que los
jóvenes al consumir la información
política casi únicamente
the influencers en redes sociales se
vuelven mucho más vulnerables a
información falsa y a discursos de odio
y discursos de polarización entonces
tenemos que tener una libre expresión
que permita que la gente pueda publicar
memes caricaturas discursos políticos
sin miedo a la represión que puedan
sufrir por una publicación que hagan en
una red social mientras que produce que
protejamos que el espacio de debate
digital sea un espacio informado y
definirlo por información de calidad y
por discurso que es protegido por la ley
muchísimas gracias felipe ha sido un
verdadero placer
muchísimas gracias a ti y muchas gracias
a nuestra audiencia por ver nos pueden
seguir más contenidos como este en
france 24 y france24 puntocom
[Música]